they think driving a train is easy that  anyone can do it we know different as he  is of training the controls complex  unique quickly the signal no room for  mistakes on the clock from dawn till  dusk you know that line like the back of  your hand every stop every Bend every  Hill every sign no two days are the same  and no two trains are the same  thousands of tons and hundreds of souls  all relying on you manage the brakes  control the speed and what speed heart  pounding adrenaline rushing eye watering  breathtaking speed there's a place where  everyone is free to test their mettle to  master their machines where skills are  learned and instincts are honed a place  where drivers perfect their craft on  every type of train our every terrain so  join us we're ready when you are  we are many we are rail funds  train simulator 2015 master your  machines